kann ich eigentlich meine im wiener
essen hat genau ist eine biene arena die
proteine
ich stehe hier unten creeper kommt
einfach direkt vor mich und ich bin im
inventar und drückt escape und alles
gleich darauf an dass eine karte einfach
vor mir junge mann meinen ganzen eingang
ist weg um kaputt und alles unklar
das ist das ist doch so schock das kann
nicht sein das ist echt total schockiert
weil was das für ein wort schock ich auf
tour bin ich nach wichtige regnet
provisorisch wieder hingestellt
prora ich brauche dieses komische ding
hier direkt vor meinem grundstück ab das
ist echt traurig da steht einfach so ein
fetter erdhügel vor mir also einfach so
zweimal zwei hoch in der höhe darf den
kurz abbauen
ja ich muss doch kanzler von oder sag
noch mal da ist ein hügel der ist
zweimal zwei hoch direkt vor meinem haus
einfach der versperrten die komplette
sicht abbauen
okay okay so zum nächsten mal ich hoffe
jetzt ist nichts von und ich weiß nicht
wie ich hier runter kommen soll
ja und jetzt kommt ein skelett leckt
mich am arm opfer kam mit fliege und lea
ich gebeten kurz marmor 1
ich muss jetzt erstmal wirklich alles
einsammeln ich habe hier gar keine sicht
wie komme ich hier hoch ist die fragen
ein
kann man sich ausmalen solche komischen
stufen baumann das war richtig geil
nein kann man irgendwie mauer kann man
glaube ich richtig schöne sachen cross
machen wurde nichts gesagt hatte ich
probiere es gleich mal einfach so also
ich glaube ich habe alle meine sachen
wieder bekommt jetzt eine krippe oder so
rein dann ist echt passen
das war man nicht habe kann man keine
story mein schwert ist noch nicht da
mein kesha ist nicht ab wo seid ihr
na gut dann werde ich das wahrscheinlich
heißt das nicht dass dann machen
ausreisen das aus eisen ist das nicht zu
wo ist ein kesha dann mache ich das
ausmaß einer anderen noch mal zurück
duster ist ja das ist dass es regnet und
den regen und die rutsche herunter es
regnet und ist es dunkel
meine sachen sind weg deine sachen sind
weg ja ich bin jetzt unten angekommen
und irgendwie sind aber nur die hälfte
der sachen da das ist blöd weil
wahrscheinlich fünf minuten des bauern
blabla ja ja ich versuche ich jetzt bloß
wollen ich hoffe die sind da oben
gelandet wäre wenn die weg sind da so
ein schönes ja da ist noch was nicht
jetzt erst mal ein paar fackeln
nicht so traurig jetzt gestorben die
zwei snacks fackeln und nur weil ich den
klaus fördern wollte das wird diese
ganze film für zwei bruder verdammte
ganze film jetzt finde ich hier irgendwo
auch in der höhle so tief drin
ich bin richtig im arsch zwei bruder du
bilder also in zukunft baue ich müsste
einfach zu ich mache jetzt surprise
surprise
hallo hallo alle sehr locker packeln was
das für ein papier mit tag gerade das
hat das coole so wir sehen uns auf einem
server können zu grüßen
ja das ist eigentlich ganz angenehme
zeit schon auf deswegen den wir gar
nicht mit supreme auf weil wir halt
schon jetzt gerade angefangen haben und
jetzt wenn wir die noch dazu holen
würden wäre das bei ihm so mitten in der
aufnahme dann ja auch damit dass ich
zeit anfangen blog aber egal wir sie uns
hier erst mal alles voll mit fackeln
jetzt gerade hell das ist jetzt
natürlich total kontraproduktiv
ich bin jetzt endlich raus aus dieser
scheißhaufen hoffe jetzt dass die
nächste klosters ergiebiger ist
hast du hast du schon vier das erst zwei
ich hoffe dass über rheinjet machen kann
du brauchst nur ganz ganz viele andere
sachen einfach ein muss noch reisen
holen ganz viel eisen brauchst du habe
ich alles da hab ich alles da ich nicht
ich möchte diese ganzen hier einfach gar
nicht haben und mich einfach also ich
hab so viel erde die kann ich auch
einfach zu bunt werden wir auch nein
obwohl ich glaube ich erst was
doch der 3g ich habe jetzt vier okay das
heißt wie gebe ich uns einig gewiss und
nochmal jetpack ein bett und ich brauche
zwei glos ton und feind iron show a was
wir dafür brauchen kriegen wir mit ästen
ein minimum stein
mini macht das minimum scherbe das ist
die die man auf der man jede seite
machen kann was ich meinte das war die
scherbe der stein der weisen widerstände
erweisen
stein der weisen erste minister selbst
in der harry potter motto david stein
der weisen der sich jetzt auch nicht so
ich weiß minimum scherbe ist die die ist
sehr selten klickt man einfach auf die
sind in so ärzten eine ordnung wenn ihr
auf der kann man jedenfalls da kann man
richtig machen dann kann sich ein item
auskommen da irgendwie so war das simon
hat das gemacht hat muss man einfach an
chemie um scherben hatte ich schon ich
habe hier schon zwei davon meine stimme
verschwindet gerade
natürlich kann ich eigentlich meine wii
noch essen
die haargenau ist eine biene in proteine
du musst so atwan zirkus' das mach ich
dich rettungslos dort auf ihr kloster
achte auf deine ernährung spaghetti ist
mit messi fleisch so was läuft hier
führt tschopp
das ist ein trick idee von kirin das
kriegst du wenn du rennst ach du scheiße
da muss man hierfür jetta brutto richtig
erkannt sag ich ja das heißt unsere
jetpack brauchst du schon mal ein paar
parisien krieg zu wenden rubber
verbrennt im rockerkrieg seibert wies
das sind diese gelten rechts liegt auf
irgendwas
da kannst du brauchst retap dafür heißt
das dass kann es aber einfach zu brav
für moslems und juden place the wall
street ab 1
aber der jedoch relativ schnell kaputt
ist kein thema ich brauche jetzt nur
cool ich hab die höhen zugebaut ist gut
das ist der wahnsinn
warum dieser mod was der alles
beinhaltet dieses paket und wir spielen
ja auch leid
das ist wirklich krass den richtigen das
spielziel ein leben lang und blickt
vornehmlich durch eine hexe habe öl ist
aber nicht ein
würde es aber nicht so heftig ich finde
es toll dass man nicht damit machen kann
wenn ich richtig sehe habe ich hier
hexenhäuschen schauen wir mal was die
alte blatt trifft vielleicht auch ein
bisschen kloster und bier hat man heute
in die kommentare was man mit öl machen
kann das interessiert mich auch schon
seit land ich glaube das kann man als
energiequelle nutzen
also ihr scheint schon jemand gewesen zu
sein
ehrlich gesagt ja das frage ich mich
auch mal wenn ich dann eh wohin muss man
ganz ganz weit weg laufen damit man
irgendwo ist wohl noch keiner war
aber dafür haben wir auch genügend ram
auf mich zu erinnern
so ist bei der scholle sind auch einfach
mal komplette die ganze welt gelaufen
ist nichts passiert also das war ganz
gut
also ehrlich gesagt ich will ich auch
meinen harry potter modus weitermachen
ich brauche gelben chart wenn ich den
habe da kann ich meinen potter
zauberstab fertig machen kann ich
vielleicht schon experience oder so luca
nicht einfach er dazu ich bin total in
gedanken das ist klasse was sehen wir
irgendwas diskutieren denkt ihr was
aussuchen was für kugel ist so gerne ich
liebe was ich tue und ich liebe
schwarzwälder kirsch schwarzwälder
kirsch jetzt einfach war das geilste für
mich ist himbeer mascarpone torte das
ist einfach nur das schwarzwälder kirsch
schwarz lackiert ist na ja ich will ein
bisschen die kirchen sind etwas anders
das ist halt sahnig und schotten sich
irgendwie so stellt der russische
support ist einfach weil sie nicht immer
die beschreiben kann nicht ob das gerät
eingesteckt ist sehr lecker ich brauche
eine schaufel und ich war noch nie so
intim
ich weiß gar nicht womit ich anfangen
soll ich könnte jetzt anfangen mir
jetpack zu machen
ich will jetzt die bienenzucht beginnen
ich will meinen zauberstab fertig
kriegen aber dass da steht das ding auch
die ganze zeit durch
ich habe auch im warmen sommerlichen
damit machen
was die wir das geschrieben mbr
das kann man nur ein en bloc machen sehr
gut aus ich das sehe kann man dort aber
ich finde dass ich liebe gewitter
minecraft einfach das ist einfach so man
fühlt sich so kann er noch als magath
raus ist gar nicht so geil das wetter
ich mag einfach im regen und gewitter
habe ich mag auch voll gern einfach
sommer wenn es zu warm draußen schön
kann oder so ein wetter ist richtig gut
gerade aber ich liebe gebiete auch wir
dass du sitzt drinnen und draußen zu
einem gewittern und so warten deutlich
regen gibt es nach fühle ich mich
richtig gut
ich bin heute noch durch den regen
gefallen und ich fand das war so richtig
heiß heute und ich war da durch den
regen
das ist dann einfach diese schüler regen
luft dies war in die kuhle bei ihnen ist
es auch einfach eklig
ich habe jetzt gar nichts mehr ich kann
hier einen bienenstock bauen ein
ventilator für den bienenstock eine
heizung für den bienenstock wird damit
die bienen sich wohlfühlen aber auch ein
fernseher kaufen aber und ein bienenhaus
dann bienenhaus da kannst du die glaube
ich dran lagern und ihnen stock ist
glaube ich dann kann die was produzieren
aber ich weiß es nicht ich habe keine
ladung fragen wenig ich möchte jetzt
auch keine löwen erzählen tut mir alles
so leid
ich möchte auf jeden fall eine höhle was
man hier gar nichts mehr also ja es gibt
wirklich verschiedene holzsorten es gibt
auch verschiedene bäume es gibt auch ein
bauwerk leuchtet glaube ich der ist blau
den möchte ich mir auf jeden fall auch
irgendwo hinstellen
oh ja ich habe alle höhen zugebaut
wollte ich mich richtig stark war das
ist schön einfach so leere fläche jetzt
hier
was ist ein kaputter kämpfte braucht man
nicht ganz einfach ist das ich hatte
keine ahnung dass die plastik nieder
zeug im pre imprägniertes gehäuse ja das
will ich machen ich wollte mir eben
solche solche stufen machen
wie heißen noch mal diese stufen
erwartet werde da stones leptin of stone
stimmte die pop stone in ein haus ich
brauche hier noch was zu machen
das ist echt sehr eigenartig
ach so ich frau es so ich brauche eine
kapsel samen kerne lag gar nicht mehr
durch was ist das hier ich brauche zwei
rechner gibt alles naviki nebenbei namen
lesen kann
ja ich glaube ich kann auch einfach mal
mein laptop neben vernehmen wir was nach
leben vermittelt ein
aber kannst du vielleicht mal knapp
hinter suchen bitte das ist irgendwie
etwas wie work mensch weißt du so was
findet man ja nicht ganz mein laptop
iran soll das heißen
sag mir auf welcher seite war es für
vize bikini oder wo wasser er war google
eingegeben ja was denn was heute sag mir
was ich kugeln sollen bitte googeln und
zwar per pn tr tr the beast karten weil
das muss irgend etwas sein womit sich im
regieren kann
gaddafis liga ist ähnlich vielleicht
auch einfach mal die konfi war dann am
besten auch wie man im öl macht also
kapsel samen kernöl beispielsweise ja
ich zuerst mal chris carpenter also
heute eine sehr soziale folgen für den
kev wir sind übrigens klatschen am ende
der mine akkus gleich alle von face käme
wären die nächsten folgen ich weiß nicht
wie du willst noch aufnehmen
das passt ja okay weil meine fans kam es
in 100 minuten vorbei dann das ist ein
wie kartenhäuser maschine bei forestry
mit ex an bord like crafting take that
needs to be powered by ein engine that
requires water for speakers of other
languages sieht
du brauchst links und rechts komplett
voll mit bronze rechts auf deutsch
nein das ist ja also ich kann zeit
übersetzt sind für dich links links die
komplette linke seite muss falls damit
zum bronze sachen sowie diesen sachen
halt diese drachen mit glas dann oben
wir da unten glas und damit unten in der
mitte glas und ganz in der mitte muss
ein
die case study cases ein danke für deine
mühe aber das wird nichts
die caseking das brauchst du das machst
du mit auch was eigentlich nur bronze
weil das machst du die casey machst du
dir einfach nur ringsrum bronze in der
mitte keinen rossel du passt eigentlich
nur bronze und klar dass ich aus kupfer
und zinn kupfer und zinn das ist bronze
gemisch das ja genau genau
naja und dann hast du vier bronze und
ich brauche irgendwas zu essen darf darf
ich für meine tolle hilfe an dich jetzt
etwas zu essen von dir haben
ich hab selber nix da bin ich heute
haben habe ich ehrlich gesagt auch nicht
darf sie aber gerne beim abholzen hätte
ich das ist sehr nett von mir aber ich
brauche halt holz einfach
das ist ein monster baum nicht
angefangen hat er gut im winter eine
facebook vorbei waren einfach jetzt die
folge schon bände
allerdings kann ich dir noch nicht
weiter abbauen weil das im frontbereich
ist das heißt du erwartest du recht ab
und macht du ruhig ich habe erstmal fünf
etf von ihr bekommt
ich sehe schon komme ich mal getroffen
na gut rein
warum ist jetzt einfach mal beenden
diese zusammen session links danke für
eine hilfe wenn ihr im wertvolle tipps
haben es jemand hier zu recht sich zu
recht findet in diesem motto gerne in
die kommentare
aber wenn ich jetzt hunger dann stelle
ich mich komplett oder
noch die hälfte oder eher auf ein herz
wenn dann irgendwann ein skelett kommt
bist du tot
na gut dann war es gewittert dann würde
ich einfach sagen wenn es euch gefallen
dürfte keiner enorm hoch geben schreibt
uns in den kommentaren welche tipps
tricks genau und wie wird man harry
potter in ried ist genau was kann man
jetzt eben machen etc
macht's gut bist dann ist dort ihr noch
schnell alles ein ja alles viel sonst
alles und ja wir sehen unsere nächsten
folge machten bis dahin soll